c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
sont les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir l'allocution du colonel
damiba le nouvel homme fort du burkina
faso s'est adressé pour la première fois
à la nation depuis le coup d'état qui
l'avait rencontré hier les ministres en
poste avant le putsch nous serons nous
étions en direct avec notre
correspondant nous l'écouterons dans ce
journal le danemark qui va rapatrier ses
soldats du magny copenhague dénonce je
cite le jeu politique salle de bamako
une centaine de soldats avaient été
déployés au mali dans le cadre de la
force takouba et quelles conséquences
aura ce retrait sur cette force anti
djihadistes européenne l'analyse de
serge daniel le correspondant de rfi à
bamako et puis succès massera opposants
tchadiens leader des transformateurs du
tchad était notre invité à ce soir nous
l'avons interrogé sur le report du
dialogue national qui doit précéder
l'organisation d'élections libres et il
sera également question de la situation
dans le sahel extraits de cette
interview dans ce journal
notre agenda est unique et il est clair
la sauvegarde de notre peuple et la
refondation de notre nation c'est ce
qu'a déclaré en substance le colonel
paul henri sandaogo damiba le nouvel
homme fort du burkina faso a pris la
parole ce soir pour la première fois
depuis le coup d'état on écoute
amis du burkina faso
as un moment particulièrement difficile
pour notre pays le burkina faso a plus
que jamais besoin de ses partenaires
c'est pourquoi j'appelle la communauté
internationale
à accompagner notre pays afin qu'ils
puissent sortir le plus rapidement
possible de cette crise pour le prendre
sa marche vers le développement
vous l'avez entendu le colonel damiba a
tenté de rassurer la communauté
internationale il a aussi tenté de
rassurer la population burkinabè retour
sur cette allocution avec notre
correspondant à ouagadougou kalidou sy
vêtus d'un béret rouge et de son
habituelle prix-là donné une allocution
de 40 minutes il explique d'abord que
l'avènement du mpr le mouvement
patriotique pour la sauvegarde et la
restauration a été imposé par le cours
des événements dans le pays afin et de
toutes parts par des groupes armés
radicaux et flics ici que c'est à des
invasions de perdre non plus à renverser
l'ex-président kaboré et il ajoute que
la sécurité sera sa priorité et qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'adjectifs rassembleur
seller refonder en incluant toutes les
forces vives de la nation il à tenir du
cultivateur opa voiliers qui peinent à
nourrir leur enfant il confirme qu'il
fait concerter avec les personnalités
comprenez ministres de l'ancien régime
d'ailleurs la rencontre s'est déroulée
hier en présence de tous les ministres
hormis le premier ministre le lieutenant
koné dalibard a tenu à les rassurer en
expliquant qu'il ne fera pas de chasse
aux sorcières et qu'il restait ouvert à
toute contribution de nantes l'ancienne
équipe gouvernementale
je referme la parenthèse revenons
discours il a également dit rassuré les
partenaires internationaux que le
burkina faso respectera tous ses
engagements internationaux dans les
droits de l'homme et l'indépendance de
la justice ce n'est pas une odeur ce
message aux partenaires internationaux à
vendredi matin demain c'est à dire la
cedeao doit réunir pour doit se réunir
pour un sommet extraordinaire sur la
situation du burkina faso pour résumer
on peut dire que le lieutenant-colonel
damiba a souhaité faire un discours
rassembleur et inclusif au niveau
national et rassurant au niveau
international
et puis sachez pour être complet que le
couvre-feu au burkina faso a été
réajustée il débute désormais à minuit
et prend fin à quatre heures du matin et
la dégradation de la situation
sécuritaire n'est pas étrangère à la
crise politique qui secoue le pays ces
derniers jours les populations souffrent
des attaques djihadiste le pays compte
un million de déplacés sans doute autant
de réfugiés ces derniers mois plus de
6000 personnes ont quitté le sud du
burkina faso pour se rendre en côte
d'ivoire laurent berthet cher
à la lisière du village ivoirien de
tougbo proche de la frontière burkinabè
quelques tentes de fortune sont
éparpillés dans la forme un refuge
précaire pour ces familles ayant fui les
violences qui a 10 tu devenu de plus en
plus fréquentes dans leur région du sud
du burkina faso
il arrive à moto avec leurs drapeaux
noirs ils vous imposent leur pratique de
la religion nous dise ce qu'il faut
faire ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
depuis le mois de septembre les réfugiés
burkinabè ne cessent d'affluer à tout
beau la plupart venus rejoindre des
proches ou des membres de leur famille
ils disent se sentir mieux protégés de
ce côté de la frontière où l'armée
ivoirienne maintien d'une présence
militaire constante
chez nous il n'y a pas de militaires
quand nous sommes arrivés ici les
soldats ivoiriens sont venus nous voir
et nous ont rassurés sans argent ni
ressources s'est réfugié survivre grâce
aux dons du gouvernement ivoirien et des
nations unies génération sont
insuffisantes et les opportunités
d'emploi quasi inexistante
nous avons trouvé une maison mais le
problème c'est la nourriture l'argent
avec lequel nous sommes arrivés ici est
épuisée je n'ai plus rien
on compte aujourd'hui plus de six mille
réfugiés burkinabè attoub aux symptômes
d'un pays dépassé par les violences qui
à dist des violences que la nouvelle
junte au pouvoir a promis d'endiguer
après avoir renversé le gouvernement
d'europe kaboré
le danemark ne décolère pas depuis que
le mali a déclaré persona non grata ses
troupes déployées dans le cadre de la
task force européenne takouba un
copenhague dénonce je cite le jeu
politique salle de bamako le danemark
qui a annoncé le rapatriement de ses
troupes quelles conséquences aura ce
retrait sur cette force antijihadiste
commandées par la france écoutez
l'analyse de serge daniel le
correspondant de rfi à bamako
il va falloir à mon avis revoit toutes
les choses il va falloir revoir le
dispositif parce que vous savez que
takouba vous l'avez dit c'est la force
européenne voulue par la france composée
de 16 pays de soldats de 16 pays où
lutter contre le terrorisme dans le
sahel c'était en fait la troisième
respiration européenne de lutte contre
le terrorisme dans le sahel la première
inspiration étant l'opération sert mal
2013 constater l'avancée des jihadistes
vers le sud ensuite la deuxième
respiration de la lutte contre le
terrorisme dans le sahel via de vue de
paris c'était par cannes qui sait 1
métastasé dans tout le sel et ménard
takouba justement la france voulait que
les européens viennent à son assaut ned
pour lutter contre le terrorisme dans le
sahel qui vous le départ des danois va
poser des problèmes
est-ce que d'abord c'était 100 soldats
qui étaient déjà là vous savez il y
avait parmi eux des tireurs d'élite et
en plus il y avait des chirurgiens
militaires est ce que d'autres pays ne
seront pas tentés par le retrait est ce
que paris ne sera pas obligé à revoir
ses plans il ya forcément dans les jours
dans les semaines à venir a estimé les
observateurs richy ya forcément paris
qui doit le revoir ses plans dans le
sahel dans le cadre de la lutte contre
le terrorisme
ce report au tchad l'adjoint la junte au
pouvoir a de nouveau repoussé le
dialogue national en vue d'élections
libres et démocratiques
ce dialogue avait été promis dans les 18
mois après l'arrivée au pouvoir de mamad
débit il devait se tenir initialement le
15 février mais il a été décalé au 10
mai 2022 une annonce sur la page
facebook de la présidence tchadienne est
justement pour parler de la situation au
tchad nous recevons ce soir l'opposant
succès massera leader du parti les
transformateurs du tchad merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau et
l'actualité qu'on va commenter et danse
mais tout d'abord j'aimerais votre
réaction à l'annoncé du report de ce
dialogue avez vous été convient
d'ailleurs à ce dialogue inclusif nous
n'avons pas été surpris mais je crois
que cela doit amener chacun à revoir sa
copie il a fallu huit mois pour que la
junte accepte l'idée d'un dialogue
souverain et d'un dialogue dont les
résultats c'est à dire la constitution
sera approuvée par référendum j'espère
que le temps de ce décalage va leur
permettre enfin d'accéder aux conditions
que nous mettons sur la table au nom de
notre peuple pour pouvoir participer à
ce dialogue la première parmi les ces
conditions c'est que ceux qui gère la
transition ne peut pas être candidat
nous présidents des conseils 1007
transition ni les membres ni le
président le premier ministre en sony le
présent l'assemblée nationale de
transition c'est ce sur quoi ils se sont
engagés mais ils n'ont pas voulu mettre
sa part riscle donc à travers votre
micro je demande solennellement de
profiter de ce sens de décalage pour
accéder enfin à cette demande qui est la
demande majeure notre peuple ensuite les
critères de juste représentation qui
sont nécessaires et de cours définir un
agenda jusqu'à présent nous nous voulons
participer au dialogue et tous les
tchadiens veulent pas super c'est parce
que les trois derniers diallo ont échoué
que nous avons l'obligation la de tenir
la dernière chance qui s'offre à notre
peuple pour créer les conditions d'un
véritable nouveau départ pour ce qui
n'est jamais venu au chat c'est à dire
la transmission démocratique du pouvoir
le succès de la junte se mesurera à sa
capacité à transmettre le pouvoir à la
fin de la transition et donc ils sont
attendus au résultat et je les appelle à
revoir leur copie
alors ok justement quelle est la
situation au tchad aujourd'hui quelle
est la place de l'opposition dans le
pays depuis l'arrivée de manette débit
savez je veux avoir une pensée pour lui
une dizaine de tchadiens qui ont été
abattus à l'est du tchad à abéché ils
marchaient pacifiquement on en a abattu
à peu près 5 à la veille et qu'on a
amené les corps pour les enterrer on a
encore vu ni les abattre et puis il
vient donc s'ajouter à la liste des dix
sept de mes militants et marcheurs qui
ont été abattus sous 7 est jeune on abat
des colonels en pleine ville et niamey
n'a donc la seule raison pour laquelle
est à lyon accepté que la junte reste au
pouvoir c'est de veiller à la sécurité
des canadiens je constate que sur cette
question de sécurité même ils sont en
train d'échouer et donc la situation
actuelle c'est aussi celle je voulais
avoir un meeting en tout cas la semaine
dernière avec des étudiants dans un
local fermé qui appartient aux
transformateurs on a envoyé un
détachement de l'armée pour nous
disperser si on avait opposé une
résistance qui auraient vite des morts
globalement il s'agit de dire quoi le
moment est venu de ne pas recommencer
les mêmes choses et donc je voudrais
dire à mon cadet le général mahamat que
c'est une opportunité en or qui s'offre
à elle en tout cas à elle la junte et à
travers elle le chef de la junte de
faire en sorte que nous nous
recommencions pas les mêmes erreurs qui
ont conduit le président deby père à la
mort et donc il faut choisir le chemin
d'avenir de ce chemin d'avenir c'est un
de s'occuper de la sécurité d'état
indien 2 d'accéder à ces conditions qui
permettront à tout le monde d'être là et
3 de transmettre le pouvoir à un pouvoir
démocratiquement élu à la fin dans une
élection à laquelle évidemment comme on
ne peut pas être juge et partie la junte
ne pourra pas prendre part enfin je
crois que la situation du tas
d'aujourd'hui est globalement peut-être
sur le ca r nous aurons l'occasion de
revenir là dessus ça doit permettre aux
uns et aux autres de revoir leur copie
aussi alors je j'aimerais votre
commentaire sur cette phrase du
président tchadien également président
du g5 celle en exercice il s'est dit
très préoccupé par le déroulement des
événements politiques et militaires au
burkina faso il condamne énergiquement
cette tentative d'interruption de
l'ordre constitutionnel
quelle est votre réaction à cette
déclaration le savez au burkina au mali
en guinée il ya une sorte d' adhésion
populaire à ces coups d'état qui ont eu
lieu même si c'est une solution
temporaire au tchad la seule légitimité
dont a bénéficié grandement le général
mohammad aujourd'hui c'est le fait que
la france a pris à peut-être très tôt et
trop tôt j'allais dire du coup d'état
qui a eu lieu au tchad l'union africaine
a entériné cela nous avons averti
l'union africaine sur le fait que si on
autorisait un coup d'état pour une
raison au tchad et bien qu'il y aura
d'autres coups d'état quant à nasri qui
cela est donc ceci je crois que le
moment est venu aussi c'est l'occasion
pour moi de m'adresser à la france et
j'ai l'occasion j'espère avoir
l'occasion en tout cas d'en parler avec
les autorités françaises moi j'ai été
formé dans les mêmes écoles que quatre
ou cinq des présidents l'autre français
j'appartiens à cette génération
multifils en tout cas des tirailleurs
sénégalais et tchadiens qui ont aidé la
france à se libérer du joug de 2 en tout
cas du dynamisme et cette génération que
j'incarne dit à la france qu'il est
temps de revoir sa copie dans la
politique africaine pratiqué dans un
certain nombre de pays africains
l'ironie de l'histoire c'est que la
plupart des pays dans lesquels on
assiste à un recul démocratique à
travers de coup d'état cdpi d'influencé
française donc en tant qu ami de la
france formé en partie par la france
jeudi à la france ou non de cette
nouvelle génération qu'il est temps de
ne pas regarder l'afrique 3.0 avec les
looks de du 20e siècle et ça ce n'est
que des amis qui peuvent le faire donc
il est aussi nécessaire à la france de
faire entendre raison à ceux qui l' a
soutenu d'une certaine manière parce que
derrière vous savez madame les coups
d'état électoraux sont aussi les mêmes
choses que les coûts de toi je dirais
militaire et donc si la france veut être
audible sur le coup d'état militaire il
faut qu'elles soient audibles sur des
coups d'état électoraux et on ne peut
pas être silencieux dans un cas et être
en tout cas avoir de la voie dans
l'autre et être entendu alors j'aimerais
vous interroger sur sur la situation ce
l on a on a traité ce sujet dans notre
journal aujourd'hui longuement est ce
que vous êtes inquiet de ce qui se passe
au mali au burkina et de ces attaques
des discussions multiplient de ses coups
d'état comment vous quelle est votre
analyse la situation je ne suis pas
inquiet parce qu'il ya des solutions que
nous pouvons apporter le tchad l'afrique
le parquet n'a faso le mali la guinée et
cetera peuvent en tout cas se mettre
debout sur leurs deux jambes c'est à
dire la jambre sécuritaire et la jambe
de développement et de gouvernance les
deux sont possibles c'est ça le chemin
de l'avenir mais je voudrais que les uns
et les autres au niveau continental
africain ou au niveau international la
france l'union européenne des etats unis
les grands pays de démocratie seniors
entendre ses cris dans le sahel se sont
pas décrits anti français ce sont des
cris au leadership serviteur est trop
afrique on ne peut pas les ignorer et
donc si on veut en tout cas tourné le
dos à ces peuples là eh bien on fera
l'erreur fatale je demande donc à nos
partenaires de l'afrique de choisir les
trains qui sont pilotés porté par des
peuples plutôt que d'être emportées
parfois par des petits groupes parce que
si on ne fait pas ça alors on aura passé
manqué une occasion et j'ai l'impression
que nous arrivons là à la ddt ou
dernière chance qui s'offre pour pouvoir
construire un avenir différent de ce à
quoi on était habitué merci beaucoup en
tout cas d'être venu sur notre plateau
pour pour décrypter cette situation
tchad est pour et pour justement
commenter ce qui se passe aussi au sahel
merci beaucoup succès massera je
rappelle vous êtes leader du parti
les transformateurs du tchad merci
d'être venu sur notre plat tout pour
finir on vous emmène au sénégal où la
première école de cinéma gratuites en
afrique un d'ouvrir ses portes à
l'origine de cette initiative le
collectif kourtrajmé et l'une de ses
stars ladj ly le réalisateur des
misérables
première rentrée des classes à l'école
de cinéma kourtrajmé de dakar pour ladj
ly réalisateur du film les misérables et
instigateur du projet c'est la
consécration de plus d'un an d'efforts
et de travail le parcours du combattant
désir qu'on veut créer des écoles
gratuites ouvert à tous est vrai que
c'est pas évident
sincèrement on pensait que ça serait un
peu plus passer les contours et plus
facilement des fonds
l'école est donc complètement gratuite
et accueille dans sa première promo onze
jeunes scénaristes sénégalais choisis
parmi des centaines de candidats 18
apprentis réalisateurs intégreront
également l'établissement cet été d'ici
la fin de leurs études ils devront
écrire et co réalisé deux courts
métrages et un pilote de série télé une
formation basée sur la pratique et les
échanges d'idées
une richesse de groupe c'est à dire
qu'il connaît dans l'aquaculture on aura
des textes
divers et parfois osées j'espère avoir
cette famille donc on composera avec les
autres scénaristes à la fin de cette
formation que vous restez soudés et
compter l'un sur l'autre pour des
projets futurs
l'école de dakar et la 4e ouverte par
kourtrajmé est la première sur le
continent africain mais la dgi et les
siens ne compte pas s'arrêter là et
prévoit d'ouvrir une dizaine
d'établissements similaires en afrique
francophone
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à célia karacena notre chef
d'édition merci à vous pour votre
fidélité rester avec nous la faut
continuer sur france 24
[Musique]